[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host on shotgun very
excited to have Jessica st. michele of
all that is joining us for her second
episode woohoo thank you so much for
coming on you kill so good to see you
again co-creator co-creator yes we've
been lots more co-creating that we'll be
unpacking this episode those that don't
know Jessica st. Michelle's shamanic
guide mystic and Chandler you can find
her links in the bio below all right so
since October of 2018 you came out as a
mystic and a Chandler on this show here
we go rushed to make sure I called my
family the next day so that they weren't
gonna be you know totally blindsided and
so blindsided but it still bite sighted
for sure yeah yeah yeah interesting he
came out on the show and then you shared
it with your friends and then what was
the receptivity from that and from
family to you know it's actually been
really cool I I got to spend eight nine
months in LA which was fantastic and
amazing in the most challenging time of
my life for sure in so many ways I
expanded and I really appreciate some
key people like you and really dear
friends that that supported that my gift
that saw the value of it and then kind
of helped give me some steps to you know
elevate that a little bit more to share
with other people and what's been so
dear and incredible is that many of
these people they challenge for even
nine months later they still talk about
it you know they still mention it they
still say how much it helped them to
deliver these messages that came in and
so so that's just been such an
incredible experience and I certainly
want to help - maybe demystify a little
bit what channeling is because I don't
think people need to go back and watch
that that first episode I can
kind of distill it down yeah yeah let's
do that okay so if you think about going
on to the TV and you're going through
all these channels you're like you know
I feel like watching The History Channel
and okay what's the on the History
Channel
oh it's only my ancient Egypt okay cool
I'm like the the TV like you can scroll
through and find what kind of channel
what where do you want to go to get a
deeper insight clarity or guidance or a
message about something that's happening
in your life and so I'm unlike the
broadcast system I got pulled down that
that information and then I become the
speaker so then I share it that's kind
of simplest way I think to say it but
we're all channels like we all are
connected to divine source all of us and
it just shows up in different ways but
if you think about anyone that goes into
a peak state or a flow state yeah
artists athletes all that they're
channeling they're channeling the energy
through them and what they do so for me
how I channel among other things is
delivering messages yeah you give the
really relatable examples that were all
channels that we we all are connected a
source and for us to be able to take
those moments of of infinite
expansiveness to connect to that source
even there's something as simple as our
breath
that that is a that that state to be
constantly tapping into is so empowering
and so important and it can be done like
you said we just had Athena Kim on the
show and she was talking about how she's
a channel for all of her art that she
makes painting on massive canvases and
these types of of relatable examples of
how for you you you said maybe not all
of us are like can connect to all the
channels though yeah so so how but then
how do you end up helping open up the
channel for someone that is asking for
something specific to sometimes you've
done like April him Lincoln when you do
like all different types of things
ancient other ancient wisdom Oh future
stuff mm-hmm yeah I don't work how does
it work so what I do is I I concern
myself a spiritual athlete so I'm doing
what I can to raise my vibration in my
frequency and doing my own self
exploration to L to work on my vibration
to be able to access those higher points
of frequency so if you have a specific
question that you have that you would
like to get some clarity on I love
working with people they're like I don't
know why this thing happened in my life
or this thing has been keeping me up or
I don't know where to go next with this
and and another thing they think about
is if they had such an open-ended
question it's like walking up to the
biggest library you've ever seen in your
life and I'm here to take you to where
you want to go so if you're like you
know I'm interested in love and
relationships like okay so we'll take
you to this section of love and
relationships you know how and but the
more drill down you get into the
specific of what you want the more
specific I can provide a guided message
for if that mean
so what I do is I say okay who here has
a message that's in the highest good
highest purpose highest love and highest
service for you because I care so much
about that level of integrity and what
comes through and I love the message so
I'm still present to you so when the
message comes through it's just like I
shift a little bit but it's surrendering
and it's the most joyful state that I
can be in like I'm smiling right now
just thinking about it because when I
get into the channeling state and I'm
serving I'm surrendering to you know
this message that comes through while
still being conscious as well and so
then that's so it could be Abraham
Lincoln it could be Lakshmi it could be
angel as it could be Kaia it could be
you know the Pleiadians it could be
everything and anything your higher self
people have passed on the everything is
consciousness everything is
consciousness so to tap into your higher
self
give me just as wise as the Buddha
because they're all connected to that
divine source of energy and truth yet
the library analogy is really good take
me to the love and relationship section
and then how do you then open up the the
channel for whatever and surrender to
whatever's coming through from the love
and relationship section of all that is
through you and then to the other how
does that process of surrendering work
just to trust and what's coming through
yeah so like when my body moves like
that that's like the energy moving
through it's like the faith so usually
when I'm channeling for someone I'm like
okay if you notice my body moving like
this is because energy starting to come
through um so that's one way of how I
know that there's a message that wants
to come through that that's ready to be
shared and that's one way I also use a
pendulum a divination tool so that you
know it's like I'm kind of like it's
kind of gives like crackly like oh I'm
hearing this name or the same or the
same and then I use my pendulum and then
once I like confirm is that it's like I
like plug-in and then
then it comes through yeah that's how my
understanding of it is right now almost
though maybe like for others that that
want this to be relatable maybe it's
something like when you ask me a
question like we asked it what's the
most beautiful thing in the world do you
ask me that like sometimes people will
like look through like take a moment
instead of react right away and they'll
kind of like the like look or feel
through themselves and through what they
know and they'll be like ah and they'll
pull it down and that's the one that
gets channeled through them something
like that something like that yeah and I
you know what this image just came to me
do you remember those really old
telephone switchboard operators that
kind of plugged in you know they they
call it you know your hireling saying
hey I want to connect this tone so
they're like okay hold please and they
like will pull out the plug and then
they plug it into the next thing you
know I think it ought you to operate
those in an old antique museum you know
in the same way it's like okay you want
to connect to blah blah blah okay cool
you know and it's like plugging into it
and then and then being that the speaker
yeah and it's really interesting because
I I also noticed that there's times
where I have my inner conflict cuz I
hear the messages coming through and I'm
like oh I don't want to say that because
I care about how the other person's
going to respond so then there's my own
like inner workings of stepping really
stepping aside because a channel just
like the TV station the TV channel is it
discriminating like oh this is a
horrible thing that's I'm saying right
now or oh this is the most incredible
thing you know like it's just delivering
information but you are discriminating a
little bit I I was you know and I'm
working that's my humanity this is this
is an object that has no humanity it
yeah you know it's just delivering
information so for me that like have the
human human in me that's like oh I don't
know how I'm gonna say that's cuz a lot
of it too is my own translation you know
it it's not like I mean I kind like hear
the words like here like as is coming
through
but up here it's just energy and then
it's like translating through so there's
there's a lot of components to it but
like having the being committed to being
a messenger then for a lot of channels
that means being the stuff out of the
judgement of what's right or wrong good
or bad yes or no I'm just saying it for
what it is and then trusting that your
soul wanted you to hear the message that
I'm delivering and then I and then for
me they're like and then let go of that
you know so if you were to walk away me
like well [ __ ] that's not what I wanted
to hear I can't take that on like yeah I
have to trust that that's you know
otherwise we're not doing our jobs
mm-hmm I'm not doing mine so normally
it's because there's some sort of a
growth that is happening between two
nerve endings of all that is like you
and someone else and that there's a
channel that's of being open for you to
communicate something of like growth to
death out there yeah something like that
and there's another thing - I was
actually we were playing with like this
little electrical device the other day
and and this the man had they had the
grounding piece the copper and he took
my hand and I felt the current from his
hand of mine from this electrical device
well then I held someone else's hand and
then I felt the energy current in my
hands going to the next person you know
so in a way like I mean the electrical
current is running from source to you
mm-hmm
yeah you know yeah and we can tap into
that ourselves but you become a
spiritual athlete we get better at it
development like an artist doesn't
become an artist basketball players of
start shooting three-pointers maybe you
know all of it all of his development
but but each each one at that level and
I'm not saying that I'm there yeah I've
been shy 14 your dreams an Olympics yeah
no and you know and it's a it's a flow
state and and those athletes really
understand the endgame and then they're
gonna do whatever they can when they've
reached a level of accuracy and
performance well what's the next level
how can I go to the next
so they're they're always finding ways
to pull it in and that's what I'm doing
in my own life as as I mystic and as a
Chandler and a healer and a coach and
you know all these things that I'm
pulling together because I want to offer
the most incredible experience that I
can for every person trusting and that
the divine is working through me and
then I'm pulling all the tools I have
here in this human life to really help
everybody elevate to be their full
potential so huge I mean it's a it's a I
guess that's a calling yeah it's been
like kind of dozens of these channels if
not even like a hundred or so yeah I
have Jennifer yeah yeah way over 100 and
it's it's amazing the insights like I
one of my favorites is I channeled some
of my friend of my entire self who is
sex God and and for him to say like you
know have fun with live like life is an
orgasm right just have fun and play and
feel it and was so cool I love what I do
so much is that as he's coming through
me I can feel that energy so that I'm
like oh yeah okay like I can feel like
what it is so like I feel like life is
like on the verge of an orgasm like that
but it's beautiful and that's how life's
been created and and I've just I've
added so I've been on my own personal
journey so like coming back to that
space again know like the life isn't it
to be joyful and and there are tough
times and there are darkness and dark
points but that's part of the journey
that hero's journey yeah and then the
life being an orgasm this can lead us
into well let's let's stick to I just
want to hit that point and we can
revisit it just that if it is for every
single one of us a constant orgasm we
just got to make sure that there's still
a playground for the grandkids so we
have to also work on solving some of the
pressing challenges
our planet faces so it's like a delicate
balance between those and the the the
orgasm is life force is life force
so it's not about I'm shirking all my
duties and responsibilities to go yes
how does in sex that's not what it's
about it's about coming from an alive
and state and being from that state of
joy and bliss yes creating like where
does like because that joy state is you
connecting to source so from that state
how can I you know solve these problems
that's a big part of Tantra is like
taking in the energy and circulating it
and unlive and yourself and raising
raising your bliss state and then
creating from that space because if
you're trying to create from the states
of and I've been doing this like trying
to create from a state of anxiety of
overwhelm of doubt of uncertainty you
get nowhere you get nowhere but to me
it's like if you're coming from a place
of joy and bliss and the liveliness and
sexiness like it's just like things
become so much more vivid and colorful
yeah impossible yeah and then so this
has been hero's journey yes for you yeah
hero's journey
yeah two years at least I'm sure we we
go through it multiple times again and
again but yeah it really started for
sure the last year I've been on a deep
hero's journey because you know what I
kind of discovered yesterday is nothing
explored nothing discovered yeah and and
I can hypothesize all I want about life
and what could be and and look at these
you know being led to these places I'm
like oh no this is really scary I do not
want to go there
but that's my mind you know and yet my
body is is guiding me to a place and
then finally when I'm like okay I'm
gonna go check out and see what this is
like being willing to go through that
darkness and now to be on the other side
of it and being like wow I really can
lead people through here is journey so
you know being willing to surrender
to a plan greater than I can see
trusting that the divine source knows
what my desires are and what I'm most
afraid of and doesn't want to harm me
you know there wants to help me get to
the state of living my divine self on
this earth because the divine seeks to
experience itself through everybody yes
yeah yes and then what is the the darker
night of the soul what is that
so I have my version but I feel like
there's a message that would like to
come through about the dark night of the
soul
okay so this is my divine self coming
through Jessica likes to take things so
seriously and we love that about her the
dark night of the soul this is a concept
that has actually had a tremendous
amount of judgment toward this feeling
of being lost of confusion of doubt of
uncertainty and of things being upended
in life when everything seemed to be
going one way then on a dime and it
seems like things things shift and then
it's not you can't get back up again and
it's not going back on that path again
and and things aren't working the way
that they used to and there's this like
it drops each person into this state of
like for Jessica she was literally on
her knees I I came to a day where I was
like if if this is my last day I'm okay
like that like and I'm feeling emotional
they get to that level of so feeling so
unworthy and then like I haven't
contributed enough on this planet and
what am I even here to do and why is it
even matter it's like all of these like
dark things they're like I have not
acknowledged not about you know like I
mean they've kind of been here but it's
like so like really come and face that
and then thank God like you know there
were like angels that came in they like
kind of like no no no like let's get you
back up on your feet like okay okay
nine-one-one you know if we got it we
got to help not in a you know mortal way
but like in a in a divine way like let's
send in the troops to like help her
remember again because and every single
one of us go through that where we are
brought to our knees and mean like why
am I here what is the point like why am
i doing all of this for what
the puzzle piece that your unique fit is
in civilization yeah unworthy or not
divine or doesn't have its place and
it's not rotting and so you need to calm
the troops to help that puzzle piece
awaken towards divinity and it's fit in
the civilizational scheme over time yeah
and I think there's something about
doing shadow work which you know we you
know there's a lot of things about
shadow work there's a lot of beautiful
things about seeing like these
basically these parts of ourselves that
we've ignored or that we find that we
deny or that we push away and I've spent
many months doing that and it also got
to a point where I just kept spiraling
and spiraling and spiraling as I'm going
deeper and deeper into this abyss of
like these dark places and myself that I
hadn't been willing to look at and to
really reach that point where I'm like
you know what today's my last day
universe I get it
someone else will finish my mission if
I'm if I'm meant to live another day
then then they'll wake up not in a way
in and I think too that there's times
where it's like you kind of like say
something like that really just want to
see I meant it
so again to go to that place you know to
finally be moving on the other side of
that and thank God it's so much faster I
can understand like I can understand
what brings people to their knees where
they feel so desperate and so hopeless
and I was like and I've had I mean I
think I have a lot to offer I feel like
I've achieved a great deal in my life
and still to gets at that point after
all that I've accomplished and I can be
on my knees beyond anything that I've
ever experienced and so it's been a
really hugely big hero's journey and and
to keep moving forward and keep moving
forward and the only thing that I can
say that I really wish is that I didn't
reach out to people I didn't reach out
to you I didn't I I felt like I need to
do this on my own and the thing is is
that with the collective awakening as it
is and there's certain people they're
being called to wake up before the
masses because if everyone were to wake
up at the same time it would be
pandemonium utter chaos and that's from
feelgood he's in the main and Tyler in
LA I have so much respect for him and
his teachings are incredible I've really
really um leaned into him quite a bit so
for some of us that are waking up but
we're going through we're doing all this
[ __ ] work you know we're doing all of it
all of us being brought to our knees and
we have to get back up and then be able
to share and help everybody else when
they start and I you know it kinda
happens and that's what I understanding
right now it's like the early adopters
on the end of the bell curve of
understanding source and spirituality
these types of things the divine purpose
that we all have on the planet and then
going through the process of
understanding that pretty much nobody
else getting it right now and that
there's a lot of updates and
civilizations social fabric that have to
happen so it's kind of like taking the
burden on the back updating the world we
live in working with the other ones that
are understand source of spirit and then
slowly over time just helping identify
other people that are like kind of there
that get it a little bit start getting
it more and more and then the big waves
come in the center of the bell curve
those larger waves of awakening come
over time and it'll be really reflective
in the in the in our news feeds in our
in our entertainment and our content
movie content things like this that the
content isn't just derp derp derp derp
waste of time but it's gonna be stuff
that's like you are a divine being that
has a unique role in this planet that is
connected to all of nature things like
that that are just like whoa like and
that's going to become like a norm like
everything will have some like
permutation of that and it things like
that that's a very beautiful and
exciting future that it is and it's also
terrifying because there's so much of
his in the unknown and then thank God
for the Pioneers they came before us and
you know we've called in being galactic
beings there is no there is no other
place to be in this galaxy than on earth
truly
like this is the place to be again
crediting feel good and so this is where
and it's like the grand dance happening
right now the biggest dance this is like
the best playground of of the Gauss yeah
one we can clear up so much karmic
things because here is duality yes rest
of the universe really does have that
kind of experience but here is duality
free choice freewill and oh by the way
you forget that you're a divine being so
we're moving through things or clearing
all karmic agreements and and you know
all these I mean there's so much to be
done here that that so many souls come
racing here to experience that because
the opportunity that they can they can
jump kinda like up level like you know
they have like a fast track and a way to
uplevel in a different way so and the
things that we gain as experience are
like being able to handle the free
choice to free will the duality the
forgetting that were divine being so
like so like remembering those things as
were birthed here it levels us up and so
that's kind of part of the like why
there's a big rush because there's so
many cool like accolades to get well and
and the earth is in a real volatile
place like they're like it has to work
if our earth does not make it it will
affect the entire entire universe which
a lot of us don't think about so there
that's another reason why you've got
future elastic being like so many
benevolent beings from other planets
that are incarnated here because they're
like dude we got it like we got to shift
this we got to move this up interesting
so benevolent beings from other areas of
the universe are incarnated on the
planet to help the spiral of awakening
yeah I mean there's forces for for all
you know for all that is there's forces
of everything but again like to be in
this space of free will and free choice
and you know and then it's cool to like
you know you start seeing people like as
you kind of like wake up a little bit
more and you start seeing really calling
you oh yeah yeah we we've done jobs
before like we're here we had this thing
they go definitely its felt like yeah
using my love you're on that's
definitely what it felt like yeah he's
in quiet I love Chinese food chicken and
mushrooms 34 I know but you know so
again like I just for any and and also
to like our earth is being bombarded
with solar flares and there's just so
much energy because it's the the earth
is moving from 3d to 5d and we need our
earthly our human bodies yeah what does
that part mean it's just like a higher
dimension where the the density of this
earth and working in duality and you
know it
ups it to much more of a unification
existence and you know it's really
profound and beautiful a controller
didn't feel good report of that I don't
know why keep plugging him but it's like
he's been a really good teacher for me
so I certainly don't want to say it's
money yeah we pull exactly we plugged
the good teachers we stand on their
shoulders also feel good get your ass on
the show let's make that should happen
yeah well we'll invite you so the so
we're the up leveling of conscious is
still awakening that that happens up
levels society to from 3d 242 5d where
it's almost as though like we're all
walking around as like we're connected a
source on the gun moment-to-moment basis
yes and so that's the one of the things
to is to be in the moment be in the
present moment field it talks about this
he says be a dot so like like really not
planning anything being so in the moment
that is that's all that is because that
is all that is and that's one of the
things that I I really learned in my own
journey the last couple of days and and
having experiences and sessions with
friends and clients that like it doesn't
matter everything leading up doesn't
matter everything to come to the merit
because all it's only one moment it's
only this so all all that is
it is also all that is in this present
all know yeah and so when our minds
wander and they're trying to prize it's
like oh I need I understand and it's
important because it helped us get to
this level of existence that you know
were here so much but really tapping
into our bodies our intuition and and
channeling into that that soul that
source is really incredible so for me so
but to get back to the yes have we done
here before in the last like thousands
tens of thousands hundreds of millions
of years have we gotten to this point of
getting from 3d to 5d and then
civilization collapses yeah I mean if
you look at Lemuria Atlantis the
Atlanteans like there were higher higher
sources higher beings that were less
dense they were more frequency based
that were here on this earth
yeah a long time ago and they're still
here some of them still hard and what do
you know yeah they say it's like you if
you're Veidt I've been told if you're if
you're frequencies higher is enough then
you can see them just like some people
can see angels and you know that's a
very high frequency and some people can
see them some people can see them
interesting so there's like gatekeepers
in science that like prevent spiritual
wisdom from like because it's like can I
prove it with the scientific method that
we're empirical here and then it's like
the Ascension papers by using that like
we don't know anything there's no
absolute truth of anything on the
scientist cannot prove anything beyond
reasonable time it's not possible
because we have the veil of unknowing
that's been placed on this earth it's
been sinning but but they cannot prove
anything to the absolute to create
certainty so none of it it's all 99.9 in
and comes down to your truth so Who am I
to tell you that how you feel about this
certain subject is right or wrong
because that is your truth and in this
moment so if you ever we can say like
the molecular composition of water is a
certain way and the gravitation break it
down a point
what if strength is it's not it's not
there that's from and I I mean that's
kind of what I've read so but people can
believe what they want and that's okay
that's the hope that a source node and
maybe the source code can't be tapped
into in the 3d world but it can be maybe
in the higher
let's also let's also the hero's dream I
just I want to say for the people that
are in the dark night of the soul and
that I mean I'm talking about like
fatigue they can't get out of bed super
depressed they have no desire to live
the way that you know life is right now
or they're feeling so so overwhelmed or
just crushing debilitating anxiety like
all that these are all especially if
it's kind of coming out of nowhere these
are part of like the symptoms of the big
energies are coming into their planet
we're trying our bodies are trying to
like get it out so we're feeling all
these things are coming up so it's all
part of the process just to say you know
connect to people that you love that
make you feel good you know the people
that like remind you of your greatness
and and do the things that bring you joy
and I've like I so wish I had really
really done that because I did it and it
just stopped took me a lot lot to you
and it finally brought me to my knees
and then thank God for literally human
angels that came in and like mmm so over
the course of a month like what it's
like completely changed and I'm so
grateful for it but these are the times
where we have to help each other we have
to and
and I have so much more humility now
like I've I feel like I've been very
very humbled and that and also not
having the judgments that I used to like
six months ago five months ago yeah yeah
they're like gone and that's another
part I think two of the clearing it's
like do you want to be a leader you want
to be an ascended master on this planet
you want to do the things you're here to
do well like let's slough off this stuff
that make you think that you're super
super awesome because guess what
everyone's awesome we're all here for a
purpose and you have no reason if I'm
your nose at anybody else that's right
when you should be helping everybody
that comes across your path and yeah and
a distinction of that is if people ask
you for help help but for you to jump in
and like oh they need help they need
rescuing not your job mm-hmm you're not
your job ah because you're not here to
save anybody yeah yeah because if you
were to look at that me like oh my gosh
they really need some help I should like
jump in there that's you divine that's
you denying the divinity in them that
they can't connect to their God source
and get what they need and pull it in or
ask for it by us assuming that we know
what's better for them it's not part of
our plan
that's not part of our path that's their
journey and to honor it and to be
supportive and there it's I mean it's a
balance that's love like I mean that's
hard for me to say but late cuz there
were so many times I was in this state
and like please someone save me please
someone save me please someone save me
please someone someone anybody please
save me I need help and it was like it
what I wasn't gonna get the help in the
way that I thought I needed but I got
exactly okay someone's house is on fire
we help they don't like ask for help
yeah or like even metaphorically their
house is on fire like they're like not
cleaning their room they're like they
don't know what their North Star is
they're not figuring it out they're
asking for help kind of like what you
were doing and if we're like not yeah so
anyway so there's that
questions rather than telling them this
is what you need to do asking them the
quite you're an interlocutor you ask
people the questions to define to define
their own truth okay so you can offer
the support what how can I support you
right now what is it that you need let
them tell you what it is that they need
but for you to say
oh look like you need identity' didn't
ya ask the questions to get what I need
yeah yeah one of the best questions that
my dearest friends asked is like what is
the most support thing I can do for you
right now
and when someone says I don't know then
what then you say okay well let's check
in with your body what is it like if you
were just asked her about it was it that
I need right now what do I need and then
hopefully they not do that but then
again if they're like I don't know how
to do that like I don't know what I need
I will see this is what I'm doing I'm
placing my hands on my body on one of my
chest and one of my solar plexus and I'm
saying like okay why do I need right now
and just take a breath knowing that
there is no wrong answer and that
allowing my body to say whatever is I
need a snack
I need food I need a snack right now I'm
hungry I got something that you say you
know him be as simple as that
and it doesn't or you know but if we're
so freaked out I I've gotten to like
really places of desperation where I was
like willing to like do things I would
never have done in my whole life you
know and but it's all part of the
process
it's all part of the journey it's just
thank you again like if you're willing
to go into those dark plate now I want
to say dark it's not about dark places
you guys is just there's things to get
out of us that don't serve us anymore
they need to come to the surface and we
need to move them out so that can be a
lot of things but it's so absolutely
part of the hero's journey like if
anyone just studies the hero's during it
all like its own nearly to a tee every
single one of us goes through a hero's
journey we've also gone to the point
where we pass along some sort of a
a guidance or like a principal to
someone else and then they go wove that
revolutionized my life I don't even ask
you for but it revolutionized my life so
it's kind of like I'm trying to figure
out where we ask questions and just
listen and we're with people hold space
all this type of stuff channel all stuff
but also that there's like sometimes
it's not even asked directly but there
can be some something that's brought
forth that can then help them achieve
what with the what they desire they
didn't even know so
yeah I'm falling Alan I just got this
message from your from your father and
he's saying that and you're like I
didn't ask for that okay I did that
totally best friends uh I literally I
was like your father's coming through
right now I don't want to hear it your
father's coming through right now and
he's saying that and it actually caused
a bit of a rift for a little bit of time
she's like I didn't ask you for that
message so and take that out of
messenger just in everyday life oh you
need to go dude edit it up I didn't ask
you what I need to do but then we also
say like wait like instead of me being
like so defensive about no I didn't ask
you for it then there's also me going
what does she say what and my dad just
say like what did my father say like was
there some important signal in there
that I'm declining because I'm not
seeing the divine moment that
potentially just happened or it could be
the opposite that you're not seeing the
person not needing it right now so I see
both of those yeah and I wonder like
which one which one which one and so I
think we can land that there's a lot of
to still break down let's what some
let's move on I'm there's still a lot
more to talk about with in here Oh
sharing dark night so those were really
good subjects so we mentioned this
throughout I want to I want to
understand it at a deeper level from
what Alan drink this water yeah
know what this water take it take this
one yeah so yeah yeah like me exactly
versus me hey uh would you like a glass
of water and you're like you know I got
one right here okay yeah yeah take it
that's the difference that that's it
mm-hmm that's an excellent way to
illustrate the difference and if like
literally I'm about to die and I'm not
gonna drink the water and you're like
[ __ ] drink the water you know and I do
and you saved my life
maybe a year down the line I'm gonna be
like I'm [ __ ] grateful you saved my
life
thank you so anyway yeah there's all
there's nuance I I really like that
point that's that's a really cool it's a
really good analogy for it
okay so let's explore where we were at a
little bit ago unpack this deeper so we
I think are there's a couple things
first is there's a hundred billion
puzzle pieces humans that have puzzle
piece their way into finding out what
their role was in civilization and now
like the puzzles gotten [ __ ] a lot
bigger the 100 billion now there's eight
billion that are like all trying to
figure out what their North Star is for
their puzzle piece what their role is
some puzzle pieces aren't figuring it
out us as quickly but the fact that all
of these puzzle pieces have been
building this planet and there's all
this beauty of free will free choice to
duality the remembering that we're doing
all these types of things that this
playground that this planet is one of
the most and it's hard because you have
to literally take yourself out of your
first-person perspective which is really
hard to do first an exercise in empathy
you can get behind another person's
perspective as best as you can then you
can get yourself out of your body and
you can think of like okay well how is
like the city doing how is like San
Francisco as a city doing well there's
the ocean that feels really good there's
like a massive concrete jungle area
filled with people that have severe
trauma sometimes an
doesn't feel as good then you go out and
you feel the whole country you feel the
whole earth then you go past the earth
into what exists beyond the earth and
potentially where we came from and this
is all part of source but I'm trying to
get people to take themselves out of
just their own head perspective and then
get themselves to these more more like
we are on a playground that is a planet
that we have to take care of because
it's the house that gives us the
nutrients we need to survive yes and so
that point there should be like ah okay
I get it we have to take care of the
house we live in
aha okay the next thing is take yourself
to the historical timeline and you see
where we came from and where we're going
and then that is this idea of holy cow
like there's a massive awakening that
spiraling upward and then now we are at
a very pinnacle moment of figuring out a
transitional moments of of awakening and
how do we enable the grandkids and their
grandkids to have a playground that is
full of just absolute awesomeness and so
that that essence is I think like is so
important to wrap the mind around so
important to understand this is what
nourishes us this is where we want the
playground to look like and that's
potentially what some of our roles are
is to make this whole narrative makes
sense for the awakening
it's your question
how do you feel about that I feel that
we have been we've been led to believe a
complete untruth in that what our roles
here and the importance of it and what
we're here to do
I mean look outside well you know how
many people are actually outside
enjoying the earth for what it is you
know and I understand we've got jobs out
of that such a conversation but time and
again if you think about the collective
that we're all connected to each other
do you think that coming from a state of
anxiety stress and overwhelm is a higher
frequency or a lower frequency than
operating from this space of bliss and
joy and if we're creating the likeness
of God do you think though you know do
you think that we that God is
overwhelming xiety I mean he has all
those things but you know but the bliss
and the joy like why is sex pleasurable
why is it even why do we get to
experience the pleasure of it why is it
pleasurable why is that potential to
experience it why are there parts on us
that are there only to exist for
pleasure for no other reason there is no
functionality of it except to have
pleasure why is it that we have the
opportunity just circulate our energy
and experience in a way that we can
connect to the divine and have our own
channel our own connection to it rather
than through religion
you know why do those things exist and
how is it not closer to the divine then
running around and do you think that
people are living in a space of bliss
and joy do you think that they're going
to take care of things better you know
when they have an appreciation for the
love and the beauty of one of one
another of their connection to their
self see themselves with the earth when
did they make better choices from that
state yeah you know so it's you know so
much of what I've been learning has been
about how can they make joy the center
of my experience and doing things from a
place of joy because who wants to play
with people that are joyful and who
wants to play with people that are like
you know that that are just you know
just you know and all was good
everything's perfect
there isn't that you know and that's the
word thing to say Mary phrase everything
is exactly as it is everything we're on
the dowel right exactly as it is I mean
we haven't lost it and we need to find
it it's exactly it's exactly as it is
and this is something that like I really
I actually challenged it for a client
and it was a huge huge that shift of my
paradigm so much because I started
saying everything is perfect as it
should be you know I was like no no no
because if you say something is perfect
then you become attached to the
perfection and then everything else is
deemed imperfect but for you in this
moment is perfect five months from now
that might not be perfect you know so
and then everything is as it should be
well if I'm telling you well you know
what everything is as it should be Alan
so right now you know that so then
you're having a conflict and you're
feeling bad that I should be grateful
when I'm not feeling grateful I should
be so now I'm feeling bad that I'm not
feeling grateful and that it you know it
does this thing or everything is as it's
meant to be that really throws people on
their head but to say everything is
exactly as it is like like when I might
feel into the energy of it because
that's something so huge to use the
energetics and everything that we say
and what we expressed and in this world
everything is exactly as it is like
there's just there's like this solid
solidness to it and to move each moment
mean like everything is exactly as it is
everything exactly as it is and I'm you
know no good just a different way of
operating
yeah not being attached a good bad right
or wrong perfect and perfect because
everything is exactly as it is
everything is exactly it is is and we
also have a Northstar that we're
pursuing in that yeah yeah that type of
thing
Jessica thank you again for coming on
days in which embody that's the
difference yeah you embodied a state of
consciousness
yeah and literally felt rather than
intellectual and yeah thank you I got a
few for you yeah big love thanks Jessica
thanks everyone for tuning and we
greatly appreciate it we'd love to hear
your thoughts in the comments below on
the episode let us know what you're
thinking
also do share more content like this
around the world do your friends
families co-workers people online on
social media get talking more about the
hero's journey about mysticism about
channeling about BDSM let's eradicate
the taboo from these subjects and move
our civilization forward you shout out
to round of August for producing and
directing thank you very much Ron and
also do check out the links in the bio
to not only Jessica but also the
simulation our patreon our
cryptocurrency links down there our
PayPal link is down there get supporting
the artists entrepreneurs the people
around the world that you believe in
also design cool merch like this shirt
what's the most beautiful thing in the
world get paid for designing that merch
and also spread thought-provoking
questions thanks everyone for tuning and
we greatly appreciate it build the
future manifest those dreams into the
world we love you please
[Music]